>>> NOW SOME NEW CNN REPORTING
ON A WITNESS WHOSE TESTIMONY
WOULD BE AN IMPORTANT BUILDING
BLOCK IN ANY CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS CASE AGAINST DONALD
TRUMP.
A KEY FORMER WHITE HOUSE FEDERAL
OFFICIAL TOLL PROSECUTORS TRUMP
KNEW THE CLASSIFICATION PROCESS
AND FOLLOWED IT ALL THE TIMES IN
OFFICE.
THIS IS THE LATEST INDICATION
THAT PROSECUTORS ARE SEEKING
EVIDENCE SUGGESTING TRUMP
UNDERSTOOD THE PROCESS FOR
DECLASSIFYING DOCUMENTS.
THAT COULD UNDERCUT THE CLAIMS
THAT HE AUTOMATICALLY
DECLASSIFIED EVERYTHING.
HE TOOK WITH HIM TO MAR-A-LAGO.
BREAKING THIS REPORTING AND
JOINING THE CONVERSATION IS ZACH
COHEN, PAULA REID AND SHAN WU
ARE BACK WITH US LET'S TALK
ABOUT WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT.
THIS OFFICIAL WHO SERVED IN BOTH
TRUMP AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATIONS, A CAREERIST FLR
WITH THE CLASS FEW INDICATION
PROCESS, HAS SPOKEN TO
PROSECUTORS ABOUT WHAT DONALD
TRUMP KNEW, WHAT DONALD TRUMP
WAS TOLD, WHILE HE WAS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE ABOUT THE PROCESS HE
UNDERSTOOD THE RULES.
PLUS SPOKE DON McGAHN, BIG
PLAYERS, SMART PEOPLE, CLOSE
PEOPLE TO DONALD TRUMP, THEY ALL
KNEW THE PROCESS AND TALKED TO
TRUMP ABOUT IT AS WELL.
SO WHAT TRUMP SAYS PUBLICLY
CONTRADICTS WHAT YOU HAVE
LEARNED HERE.
>> EXACTLY.
THIS IS A CAREER OFFICIAL.
IT'S SOMEBODY WHO ADVISED THE
TRUMP AND OBAMA ADMINISTRATIONS
ON THE CLASSIFICATION PROCESS.
IT'S SOMEBODY WITH DIRECT
KNOWLEDGE OF HOW THOSE TWO
ADMINISTRATIONS FOLLOWED THE
PROCESS AND EVEN CITED SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES ABOUT TIMES THAT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION FOLLOWED
THE CORRECT PROCESS.
SO IT'S REALLY INTERESTING TO
HEAR WHAT THIS OFFICIAL WAS
ASKED BY PROSECUTORS IN BOTH
DIFFERENT INVESTIGATIONS.
IN THE TRUMP PROBE, PROSECUTORS
WERE REALLY AGGRESSIVELY FOCUSED
ON ANYTHING THAT HAD TO DO WITH
FIRSTHAND INTERACTIONS WITH
TRUMP, ESPECIALLY ABOUT
CONVERSATIONS RELATED TO THE
DECLASSIFICATION PROCESS.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT PLAY OUT IN
THE TIMES OF THIS INTERVIEW.
WE HAVE SEEN OFFICIAL GOS IN AND
TESTIFY BEFORE THE GRAND JURY
ABOUT THE DECLASSIFICATION
PROCESS AND ABOUT THEIR
CONVERSATIONS WITH TRUMP.
COMPARED TO THE BIDEN INTERVIEW,
IT WAS VERY DIFFERENT.
THIS OFFICIAL WENT IN AND IT WAS
ABOUT THE MECHANICS OF THESE
BOXES.
HOW DID THEY GET PACKED, WHO
PACKED THEM AND HOW DID THEY
MAKE THEIR WAY TO DELAWARE.
VERY DIFFERENT AREAS OF FOCUS.
TRUMP TRYING TO GET A SENSE OF
HIS MIND SET, AND BIDEN, THEY
WANT TO HEAR MORE ABOUT
LOGISTICS.
>> CORRECT IF I'M WRONG, TRUMP
OES SEEMS TO BE MORE SERIOUS.
THE BIDEN THING IS A MISTAKE.
IT WAS SOMETHING BAD AND WRONG
HAPPENED.
BUT THE CONTEXT, THE SCOPE OF
THE TRUMP INVESTIGATION.
>> THE BIDEN INTERVIEW DID NOT
MATCH THE INTENSITY OF THE TRUMP
INTERVIEW AT ALL.
HE'S REALLY CHARACTERIZED THEM
AS DIFFERENT TONES.
>> CIRCLE BACK FOR MORE DETAILS
IN A MINUTE.
THE CASE YOU'RE TRYING TO BUILD
AGAINST TRUMP, WE FOCUS ALL THE
TIME FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF IS A
GRAND JURY WITNESS, FORMER
SPOKESMAN, BUT IF IT YOU'RE
BUILDING A CASE, SOMETIMES IT'S
THE LESS GLAMOROUS WITNESS WHO
IS CAN DO THE NUTS AND BOLTS.
HE KNEW THE RULES.
HE WAS REMIEN
NDED OF THE RUL.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN
DOING.
THEY ARE BUILDING THAT KIND OF
FOUNDATION AS TO HIS MIND
SETTLE.
AND THE POINT IS YOU CAN TELL SO
MUCH NOT ONLY FROM THE
INTENSITY, BUT THE KINDS OF
QUESTIONS.
IF YOU'RE FOCUSING ON MIND SET,
THERE'S PERSONAL EXPOSURE HERE.
IF YOU'RE FOCUSING ON FACTUAL
QUESTIONS WHO ARE PACKED THE
BOXES, YOU'RE LOOKING ALL THE IS
THERE A PROBLEM WITH THE WAY
THIS STUFF GETS TRANSMITTED AND
PRESERVED, NOT DID SOMEBODY
COMMIT A CRIME.
>> WE SHOWED THE OFFICIALS.
THESE ARE NOT NOBODIES.
THESE ARE SENIOR PEOPLE, TWO OF
THEM ARE LAWYERS.
NOTHING APPROACHING THAT TRUMP
HAD THAT STANDING ORDER THAT I
COULD SNAP.
NOTHING APPROACHED THAT.
I CAN'T IMAGINE ANYONE THAT
WORKED AT THE WHITE HOUSE AFTER
ME WOULD HAVE SHRUGGED THEIR
SHOULDERS AND ALLOWED THAT TO GO
FORWARD.
KELLY MAKING THE POINT THAT WE
UNDERSTOOD THE RULES ASK WE WERE
NOT CASUAL ABOUT THEM.
THEREFORE, THE PROCESS SHOULD
HAVE BEEN FOLLOWED.
>> HAVE YOU EVER HEARD OF THE
DECLASSIFICATION ORDER?
THEY HAVE NEVER HEARD IT.
CLEARLY, THEY HAVE NEVER SEEN
IT, IT LIKELY DOESN'T EXIST.
IT REALLY UNDERCUTS SO MANY OF
THE PUBLIC EXPLANATIONS AND
PUBLIC DEFENSES THAT THE TRUMP
TEAM HAS PUT FORTH.
HE'S TRYING TO DRAW THIS FALSE
EQUIVALENCY BETWEEN THE TRUMP
DOCUMENTS AND THE ONE FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND THE ONE THAT
HAS BEEN CLOSED INTO PENCE.
WE KNOW FROM OUR REPORTING, EVEN
THOUGH BIDEN AND TRUMP ARE
FACING THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION SWOO THE POSSIBLE
MISHANDLING OF DOCUMENTS, THOSE
ARE DIFFERENT IN TERMS OF
VOLUME.
DOZENS OF DOCUMENTS VERSUS OVER
100.
ALSO THE CONDUCT.
COOPERATION.
POSSIBLE OBSTRUCTION.
THE TYPES OF QUESTIONS
PROSECUTORS ARE ASKING, THEY ARE
JUST ASKING ABOUT BOXES AND
PACKING.
THE TRUMP LAWYERS PROBABLY WISH
THOSE WERE THE QUESTIONS THEY
WERE ASKING ABOUT THAT
INVESTIGATION.
AND IT'S CLEAR THEY BELIEVE THE
TRUMP IS IN THE COURT OF PUBLIC
OPINION.
HE DIDN'T KNOW THE PROCESS OR
HAVE TO FOLLOW IT.
IT'S SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE IT
SHOWS NOT ONLY OUR REPORTING,
BUT THIS IS THE TESTIMONY THAT
THEY ARE GETTING IN BOTH CASES
FROM AN EXPERT.
>> AND THE EXPERT' TESTIMONY
HELPS THEM ABOUT WHAT WAS
HAPPENING.
WE KNOW THE WITNESS WHO HAD EYES
ON SO MUCH OF WHAT TRUMP DID.
THE FORMER ADVISER, AND A TRUMP
LOYALIST.
BASE E
D ON WHAT THE
AND THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THOSE
WITNESSES, CONNECT THE DOTS.
>> WE HAVE SEEN THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL IN THE TRUMP
INVESTIGATION REALLY SORT OF
FOLLOW THE ADVISER IN THE
INTERVIEW AS A ROAD MAP FOR THE
TYPES OF EVIDENCE THEY HAVE BEEN
WORKING TO SECURE IN THE TIME
SINCE.
THEY HAVE BEEN PUSHING TO GET
THESE RECORDS FROM THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES THAT INCLUDE
COMMUNICATIONS ABOUT THE
DECLSIFICATION PROCESS, WHICH WH
DID HE CLS IF I.
WE KNOW THEY BROUGHT IN SEVERAL
SENIOR TRUMP OFFICIALS,
INCLUDING ROBERT O'BRIEN, WHO
TOLD THE GRAND JURY THAT WE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH TRUMP
SPECIFICALLY, DIRECTLY, AND WE
TOLD HIM AND MADE CLEAR THERE
WAS A PROCESS FOR DECLASSIFYING
THINGS.
YOU CAN'T WISH IT TO BE TRUE.
THE GRAND JURY IS HEARING THE
TESTIMONY THAT THIS FORMER
OFFICIAL LAID OUT AS IMPORTANT
MONTHS BEFORE.
>> CRITICAL REPO